- [Mark] Yeah, so
Patricia, what's going on?
- I'm dying.
And I'm a fellow HIV,
cancer,
my chest.
- [Mark] So you went to the doctor when?
- Two weeks ago when I had two strokes.
- [Mark] You had a stroke?
- Two strokes.
- [Mark] Two strokes?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you went to the doctor?
- Yeah, I found out I was sick.
- [Mark] When you found
you have lung cancer?
- Breast cancer.
- [Mark] And you're HIV positive?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow. How do you
think you picked up HIV?
- By someone doing
something fucked up to me.
- [Mark] You had sex with somebody...
- When I was asleep, they had sex with me.
- [Mark] Oh, that happens here.
- So, I'm telling my story now.
It's my last time telling my story.
So, that's me.
- [Mark] So what are you gonna do now?
What do the doctors say
about your lung cancer?
- It'll kill me off-
- [Mark] Breast cancer.
- It'll kill me off because
it spread through my body already.
- [Mark] It spread through your body?
- Already.
So I get real sleepy and shit.
So I'ma sleep my time away
until it's time for me to go.
It's getting cold out here too.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's getting cold.
- So I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 33, I'll be 34 December 1st.
- [Mark] How are you processing
all this new information?
Are you back to using again?
- No, I don't use anymore.
- [Mark] Good for you.
Sometimes stress brings...
- Yeah, sometimes it's that way.
- [Mark] Do you have any
family you can go see?
- No.
- [Mark] Nobody.
You're just living on
your own and that's that?
(cars pass by)
- Tell everybody my story.
That's it.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- That's it.
(car zooms by)
- [Mark] All right.
All I can say is good
luck to you. I hope...
- I hope I'd be in a
better place...up there.
- [Mark] Yeah.
This is about as bad as
place as you can ever find.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
Good Morning.
- [Mark] All right, Patricia.
How are you?
- Okay.
- [Mark] So what's the latest?
- January 18.
- [Mark] January 18th
you're gonna start with-
- Chemotherapy.
- [Mark] Chemotherapy. Good for you.
Good for you.
Because you were debating
whether to do that or not, right?
- Yep.
I'ma do it.
- [Mark] So when you wake up
in the morning, do you go,
"I can't believe this is happening to me."
Or, what kind of thoughts
go through your head
when you're alone?
- [Patricia] Scared.
- [Mark] Scared, sure.
- [Patricia] Yep.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- [Patricia] 34.
- [Mark] 34.
Still young.
- [Patricia] Birthday was December 1st.
- [Mark] Yeah. Happy Birthday.
- [Patricia] Thank you.
And, I'm a HIV negative.
- [Mark] Oh, so you're not HIV positive?
- [Patricia] I'm not. No, I'm negative.
- [Mark] Oh, I thought
you told me you were-
- [Patricia] I have breast cancer.
- [Mark] Yeah, but you
were HIV positive as well?
- [Patricia] Nope. I found out yesterday.
I'm negative.
- [Mark] Why do you
think you were positive?
- [Patricia] Because, I was having sex.
A friend. But...
- [Mark] So you were having sex with-
- [Patricia] A girlfriend.
- [Mark] With a girlfriend?
- [Patricia] Yeah.
- [Mark] But she has HIV?
- [Mark] You assumed that you'd get it?
- [Patricia] Yeah.
- [Mark] You think that's a smart move?
(chuckles)
- [Mark] I'm not so sure.
Okay.
- So I HIV negative.
- [Mark] That's a help.
- Breast cancer, stage three.
So, January 18, I start doing therapy.
I'm ready.
- [Mark] Excellent. Good for you.
- [Patricia] Thank you.
- [Mark] I like your positive attitude.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you for coming by again.
- You're welcome.